حب وولاء وابديه هذا ما يمثله الالماس
واكثر بالنسبه للكثيرين الصله العاطفيه
تجعل لهذه الاحجار قيمه اكبر وفيما يرتفع
الطلب العالمي على الالماس هناك تجمع جديد
بدا يتكون ليصبح مركزا عالميا للالماس هذا
هو برج الماس في اماره دبي والذي يعد
مركزا لسوق الالماس في
المدينه ويقول بيتر ميس مدير سوق دبي
للالماس ان الالماس سياتي باشكال متعدده
فهذه الماسه الصفراء على سبيل المثال
جميله وتصل قيمتها الى 350 ال دولار وعن
سبب تحول دبي الى مركز لالماس يقول ان
الاماره مرت بثوره فريده خلال الاعوام
الماضيه لعده اسباب اهمها سهوله اقامه
الاستثمارات هنا والبنيه التحتيه التي
تسمح بذلك نظرا لوجود احد اكبر مطارات
العالم لكن البيئه الاستثماريه المشجعه
ليست السبب الوحيد الذي يج ذب تجاره
الالماس فهناك ايضا التغيير الحاصل في
طبيعه
الزبائن ويشرح في شال ميثا مدير شركه
دامسون ذلك بالقول ان هناك تطورا ملحوظا
في شكل الاستهلاك فسابقا كانت الولايات
المتحده تعتلي قائمه الدول الاكثر
استهلاكا للالماس كما ان الصينيين والهنود
يحتلون مراكز متقاربه في المرتبتين
الثانيه والثالثه واليوم تستهلك الصين نحو
11 في من مجموع الاستهلاك العالمي للالماس
بينما يتراوح الاستهلاك في الهند بين 10
و1 في وبالنسبه لتاجر كفي شال يوفر هذا
المبنى كل ما تحتاجه شركته فمثلا هناك
خدمات التنظيف التي تزيل الشوائب عن
الالماس اضافه الى احدث التقنيات في حظ
الماس
وتخزينه ويحتوي هذا المبنى على احجار
كريمه بقيمه تزيد عن نصف مليار دولار وهو
امر يتناسب مع الالق الذي تشتهر به اماره
دبي
[موسيقى]
y